yeah Dave Maloney was was talking about how
quickly and their effectiveness off the rush
and we just saw it there there's binski coming out
with it Ryan lingren looking for a lane Long Shot
score benino was in front but it's Ryan
Lindgren getting the goal to give the
Rangers the lead and [__] in front it starts
behind the net the Rangers get in on the four
check they caused a turnover and now they go
to work when they get it back to the point
watching front of the net two big bodies
in blue and a couple of white sweaters as
well Lucin doesn't see it head up all the
way by link TR in for the face off one it
trba shot gloved by Lucan and he holds it
Savanah Jad down low knocked away cousins
try to clear kept in by panan panan moving
feeds a bad back to paner he's got room he
scores art T panan it's a power play goal
it's two nothing Rangers tro wins the faceof
and Buffalo doesn't touch the puck again unless
they block a shot Total Control by the Rangers
from both sides and that shot Lucan looked like
he might have been screened well how about the
accuracy of the shot oh Lucan didn't even know
the puck was past him and now the sabes have
given up two more first period goals 46 on the
season in the first period it's the most in the
leag chance for tuck but he missed it on the
backand he recovered and shurkin made a save
we'll get another look and trouba kind of with
the with the palm of his hand gave a little bit
of a push from behind at looking to shoot it's
deflected on the way in comes back to delene
Middle St checked by brazinski Greenway tied up
by Schneider fights him in score what a shot by
Rus toad Greenway with a big play and delene
with an outstanding shot and buffalo is on the
board that's his sixth power play goal watch
26 in white drift in drift in and that thing
is off the stick in a split second and in the
perfect spot darene kept it alive kept it going
and then just reads watch him walk in walk
in and in the net well Fier got it out of the
Zone Rangers have it Panera nice pass La forier
save off the glove the other night with a game
winner has another one tonight Matthews
has another one tonight the big guns are
out they're going here's Quinn moving in Jack
Quinn shoots and scores and the sabes have tied
the game Quinn we mentioned him at the top
this is only his third game we talked about
he can he can shoot the puck now the now the
Rangers again this is we saw this last night
just kind of backing in too much stick checking
Rangers have plenty of players back Rangers are
only credited with one hit in that first period
and you know maybe that part of the game as they
need to pick up a little bit Fox and peterka
go for it fox went down Rangers able to clear
it out off the boards wheeler picks it up
Savanah J to the net here's crder save R
score
miked oh that line worked well on that play
second period but they get it going here Fox
with the diving play to get the puck going
pass the four Checker now the Rangers find
themselves a little bit of room wheeler to
crrider for the shot beautiful save here by
Lucen but right there is M's Advantage ad to put
in another one he has been hot 12 points tro to
zabana Jad Fox to paner save rebound another
save Zed trying to slip one past Lucan where
it looked like he had a wide open net and it
looked like he had another good chance here
this shot will come from here and there's Lucan
and it just stretches oh when power moves in on
the back hand with Block brzinsky in front save
on VC and Lucan Dives out they're looking and
look shaky in the first period Bo he's made
some good saves here yeah there's one here on
the deflection there's the second one alen
took a hit from tro there's a lead to Ryan
Johnson Johnson nice pass olon save a big save
by shurin some big saves well shurin makes one
here good passing through the neutral zone and
Ryan Johnson over to olison made a they scored
early in the second period beneran with laier goes
across TR check shoot save no hit the they hit the
post good pass through to laier dropped it off
for panan CH treding to hit the open man was
black chance for L reier excellent chance here's
the puck movement again gain the Blue Line some
drop passes and then there it is and can't say
enough for what they've done to sacrifice but
he's made it happen as well yeah and uh certainly
I'm sure uh there's a lot of pride in the troch
family for what he's accomplished CH in Front
Middle St save but he put it in the rebound
middle stat stayed with it and the Sabers have
come back again to tie the game around him and
and shesterkin had trouble with the puck went
off the side of the net and you here's the the
initial pass gets deflected as Schneider tries to
make the play and middle stat just stays with it
regain the lead and now it's a 33 game pitlick
finds VC VC Tred to get it goodro pitlick shot
is stopped by Lucan and and good Row one sliding
into the net saan Jad up the boards troch forced
out of the Zone take away by tuck tuck breaks
in shorthanded tuck shoots and a save bch to
stking lead pass that was tipped away Rangers
blocked it take it back to to Middle St Middle
St to the net sa Shin he saved the game right
there Miller moves in power fell down Miller
to tro check he's in he missed off the glass
middle stat comes out tro trying to get back
middle stat save rebound CH save just St it
with two more Beauties he sends it back to
Fox 245 to go on the overtime crrider with
saan Chad that's deflected across a stick
went down that would belonged to Quinn
here's the bed to the net Around the Net
pass score the Rangers winning in
overtime and then down the other end after he
had made a couple more zabana Jad is going to
be so patient hold it hold it hold it throw
it in front and into the net Lucan and the
goenda he's got to shoot right he's got to
shoot got to shoot I'll play him like he's
going to shoot the net was wide open and krider
finishes off the beautiful pass from Saban Jad
that is just a gorgeous patient play as
krider is able to get the game winner go